[Applause]
four please one yes yes all from up
north
yes yes math what's on the menu pan
roasted pigeon recipe chewin on a ball
Strong's asparagus are you is that slow
yeah okay
bye Santa let's do one together yeah
let's go
I've also secret about cooking pigeon
not overdoing it don't overdo it exactly
now there be marinated in time garlic
pigeon in yeah and that's the sort of
noise you want to hear yeah just that
nice little sizzle mushrooms in yeah
yeah touches too lots and a little touch
of garlic in there yes okay asparagus in
lots a little chives right pigeon out
yeah that's gonna sit there and rest
salad Rockets some walnuts in there yeah
plain mushrooms yeah umm some asparagus
on no way to sell on there it's a warm
salad and then from the Bristol turn it
over so it's flat side down and just
slice the breast and then finally we'll
have a little bit of vinaigrette over
the end and look bingo anything
complicated there no chef
okay first order okay on order four
covers Table three yes full PG salad for
skate for pan perdu yes I like Lord
orbit my kitchen
we all know each other through the
police force I love everything about
food I just you know love trying new
things and don't get a bonus because I'm
gonna passion for food we used to have
people being fired with us so if worse
comes to worse we can always hang call
them to the cooker bring on Gordon
he's not even gonna be able to swear and
if he does it's probably Carter he's
going down
we're gonna sell 150 plates no problem
just be very very careful when you're
cooking these yeah they overcook in
seconds yeah very quickly with your
tongs out quickly good yeah yes why did
you join the police force
well my modeling career never took up
for a little enjoy it
I do philosophy warrant are packed with
emotion no yeah exactly
I try to use cooking to get all over
that goes so this please you happy yes
yes yeah
so Mike Table twelve let's go
[Music]
golly how are you hi everyone nice to
see you thank you for having me back I'm
very good to see you
is this in the way for the short three
four if you count the show a month later
you said bastard you're still carrying
it around yeah but I had to pick it up
today and I said I'll pick up golden two
and they were honest it didn't Gordon
you're an Ender saying that you should
be winning those honey machine stars
have you got
[Laughter]
okay good to see you again lovely to be
here thank you having me back we enjoyed
our starter the asparagus was nice about
the pigeons pigeons are white but a
pigeon that belongs in Trafalgar Square
no it doesn't ask you sit there's a
woodland pigeon Jonathan you can quite
see James when you were child you were
sort of a went on a child you know what
I would eat you know I would eat eggs
my brother's called me egg boy and I was
in the top bunk as well well you must
have something more than sort of eggs
only well my mum was an OK cook but you
know we were you know pleading Papa here
but we weren't a well-off family so she
sometimes do a castle at the weekend but
it was just a big ol bit of meat you
know simony shoots what kind of white
beans in there and anything said
available uh-huh and that was fine all
we used to have I used to like chicken
and chips and we heard that cage you
know you know but it wasn't we didn't
have much else we used to have a lot of
food that you buy in stores but I
remember remember Vesta yeah they used
to make the kind of beef was Otto that
was almost exotic food overhead right I
want to talked about Fanny Cradock
please don't amazing woman and this year
we'd also campaign to help find and you
find if you're looking for your aunt
Fanny I understand that and I afford
that but why not just do what most
promote used to do a little bit of lippy
a long long way okay double bubble you
never know about that
you're the one with the man boobs I've
actually not really got members what
I've got those I'm carrying a lot of
weight down there fill that throw that
down it Fanny Cradock you're the very
last person to actually India I didn't
realize that my whole body my mini song
didn't do we go well I can't really
remember that much so I so probably not
should we have a little look at it
Jamie please so this is you back in 1987
yeah as a skinny mini your shall was the
most successful cook we show everyone
think probably yes what do think was the
key to that success what I could cook
but I thought believe you had any formal
training as a cook did you
what do you call for more training for
bigger cook there aren't people like
that on TV anymore
no they're really armed cuz you're
actually saying clearly and very good at
what you do what kind of advice would
you give to any woman out there that's
thinking of becoming the next sort of TV
cook what you're looking for we leave
some of the personality but but it's a
difficult thing because you don't have
someone to be false
well thousands of them have a quick look
at this fight so this is bitter amateur
Fannie's yeah bit amateur fan is why
should've oh she let me to play do you
want to be Nigella yeah yeah I thought
about a hundred grounds of chickpea
flour
you know I won't show you my my tits on
TV they might show you my tattoos you
know that it looks so she went on a
gonna head there's a terrible haircut
suck a hairs on backwards straighten
hair now I'm tempted to drink it
yourself but no I think she might be
emotionally damaged I could see that
they've all they were all obviously
quite confident yes they've all got
different things to work for them
against them they need to be strong
charismatic and someone's not gonna melt
under the pressure you want to get one
of those female bodybuilders with the
long Texas [ __ ] man I'll see you
later
holy [ __ ]
the pigeon was lovely actually I really
like the asparagus with it as opposed to
warn us one of my friends had the same
obviously pigeon it was a bit more
cooked and it was a lot nicer right
results ladies starters how could you be
okay here we go mm-hmm now ladies a
number of customers before their starter
it's thirty four hour 15 undercooked
undercooked wear pink is perfect when
it's brown it's fun I know don't go down
yeah I'm gonna get to you bounce back
yes on the station let's go ladies yes
next on the menu
never mind the scallops will my wetsuit
stay dry why is it like this when you
get to this stage always person 4p time
for the main course
mouth-watering roast skate with beetroot
and Parmesan and I share a bloody awful
drink with Janet Street Dracula
welcome back the F word time for the
main course
[Music]
and Rosie skate wing delicious very
sweet easily get hold of and more portly
very cheap pat dry season hot pan olive
oil
but uh now the fish is taking a
completely different color base
and that butter is on the verge of
becoming a beurre noisette and not brown
butter
[Applause]
beautiful slides off playback leave that
to rest for two minutes now the garnish
lettuce
salt pepper balsamic vinegar
olive oil rosemary
thirty Seconds hot pan
beetroot
I look at the plagues on that beat room
now capers parmesan parsley
vinegarette
as the parmesan starts to melt take it
off
victory ten seconds in the pan
and well that beats spinach any day
and that has to be the perfect way to
bring escape back to life pan-roast
escape with beetroot and parmesan done
Joe yeah the state sticking yeah what's
the pan hot enough because look let me
show you something look yeah nine of
color come on if it's boiling you can
completely different flavor okay yeah
quite thick the huh got to base them you
don't base them they're not gonna cook
on top yes but you were in good nice
right good good watch when you place
them in there what's your fingers Lisa
please that's nice beautiful color come
on you doing very well done let's go
yeah
are you look at this [ __ ] middle
school why is that when I'm
concentrating what I'm trying to work on
what is the word for more why're you
here we go it looks lovely thank you
watch out here's the food snob with the
big job in here is a food packed full of
vitamin b12 iron and protein which is
produced in Britain but unbelievably
almost nobody eats it
in fact we Weis 36 million tons of it a
year which is a dreadful strain I'm
gonna get you all to eat blood
we should eat more of it but us Brits
find the thought of cooking with blood
pretty hard to stomach no that is
something I definitely wouldn't be
putting past my lips I think it's the
thought of it that puts you off
straightaway if you he's gonna tell me
it was gonna be good for you I would I
would I would taste it yeah I would eat
it does sound a bit sort of like hammer
house of horror a type of approach to
cooking no it feels a little bit to
devil-worshiping for me I'm not a
vampire it might be out of fashion but
protein-rich pig's blood has
traditionally been used in cooking I'm
going to try some of the world's best
beloved recipes so I'm here at this
abattoir to source some prime fresh
ingredient as in all of it was the pigs
are stunned before being bled
I'm taking my blood to renowned butcher
David lachemann to learn how to make the
classic British blood dish black pudding
great it's very rare that we actually
get fresh blood nowadays after cooling
for a couple of hours the blood oxidizes
and turns brown the blood is mixed with
barley oatmeal pork fat and lots of
herbs and spices and poured into a
sausage machine those bits of
interesting a kind of birth control
device oh my word
luckily this goes into the boil now okay
45 minutes to an hour
nice firm Miele British black pudding oh
it's cool I'll have a bit of that icon
there's a lot more to cooking with blood
than black pudding Andy Holt is an
enthusiastic blood chef who's collected
recipes from all over the world I'm here
to learn how to cook his special Italian
blood dessert or just mix in the egg and
the justice sugar together what better
way to popularize blood with the British
then by appealing to our sweet - and
into that we're on in melted chocolate
just sound of white chocolate mousse so
far yeah then the next thing we're
putting in was the board now why after
the Italians dream up making a pudding
using blood in a way it's a way to to
use up a valuable resource because the
blood is actually very good for you
obviously it's full of iron it's full of
vitamins
hi Andy look at that super lutely for
this no honestly promise written back
memories that squealing pig has a
slightly like chocolate mousse I'm now
convinced that blood is not only good
for you delicious but it's also tasty
all I've got to do now is persuade
Gordon right Gordon what I want to do
for you right it's Italian pancakes cool
Roman tini it's like a classic pancake
mix and instead of milk you've got blood
I've never had a blood pancake you know
that egg yolk in no water no milk no no
glad again this is only pig's blood
bloody hell it's not something I donated
earlier no jeez look at that it doesn't
look that nice is this don't just go
it's easy right let it cook first before
you flip it so would you put inside the
pancake would you actually serve them by
that I think for the purposes of testing
either converting you yeah you should
have nothing but blood pancakes no you
know that looks like well I imagine your
scrotum looks like yeah I onto the board
just to smell of it though huh it
actually smells like fried blood smells
nice smells nice Thanks it's very
rubbery
is not wise to block did you Father
I'm finally come up with money you worry
there's nothing absolutely nothing
[ __ ] disgusting Janet made you to eat
the pancake
how about shot blood you're turning
fucking-a seriously you're golden and
that is a hundred percent pig's blood
did you swallow that
your possess drink here they put light
in your pencil
oh [ __ ] it's fantastic
you're not the man I thought you were
Janet I know you're a pensioner but now
you're a blood sucking pension up Janet
that is not nice [ __ ] [ __ ] vampire
no charge
Oh
[Music]
I'm heading down the Dorset Coast to go
diving one of my all-time favorite foods
spots
those speed cameras here is the [ __ ] up
I adore scallops and I've stirred them
on all my menus but most of them are
fished in our commercial scale using
dredging which can damage the seabed
the sustainable way to catch them is to
go diving and pick them up by hand which
is what I'm gonna do today handle
scalloped especially is something that
is considered a bit of a jewel in the
crown phenomenal I'm off to meet Tom
Whittle in Weymouth who's been diving
for scallops since he was 12
[Music]
got some some where it everywhere
temperature-wise what's gonna be like
down there
40 degrees yeah yeah see another in
abundance
it depends sort of where you gave but
normally what you do is basically get
down there and if there's tonnes and you
just work them yeah and if there's none
and you just swim like [ __ ] until you
find
[Music]
wedding out to the black hole prank
where we'll start out dived
marine life congregate on Rex are nearby
there's an abundance of scallops done at
the moment getting the South goes down
the west coast but costing about three
pound fifty four pounds each each each
[Laughter]
the reason that had died scallops are so
expensive is that they are incredibly
hard to catch and a diver will only pick
up a fraction of the hoard of a
commercial fisherman yeah yeah they
can't be I mean especially if they've
buried themselves into the sand but it's
all about getting your eye into it yeah
why is it like this when you get to this
stage you always person for a peek it's
the way that it's it's the rule of the
game unbelievable [ __ ] condom again
what are these things
[Music]
[Music]
visibility down here today this terrible
which makes spotting scallops that are
nestled into the sand almost impossible
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
each time Tom Mooney saves these
scallops for supper but I want to eat
mine straightaway
the fresher the better fantastic
they look amazing he'll open them and
clean them yeah so let's call up tartar
yeah basically a raw dice scallop mix
with line yeah shovel and then a little
bit of creme fraiche and mascarpone
cheese yeah absolutely amazing dive
open the scholar and then eat hello I
mean that's still pulsating now I fell
on a storm it's extraordinary
mix some creme fraiche with mascarpone
cheese lime zest lime juice
some chervil and salt and pepper right
dices scallops in and all we do now I
just hold that in there so exciting
eating raw scallops so I'm going to
serve the Scott tartare inside the
lettuce leaf so just open up the heart
of the baby gymnast it's quite a robust
leaf this so they can take this collar
absolutely delicious and there we are a
very simple scallop tartare far away
buddy
Cheers their Yelp now so tasty ten times
better to use hand-dyed i'm not drenched
and I'd rather pay double for hand dives
yeah
then cheap dread scallops that taste of
grit cheers Cheers scallops away
[Music]
first time I had skates and the fish was
better so disappointing and just greasy
the beetroot was gorgeous it had a
little bit too cheesy which gave a
really unusual flavor
okay go done ladies results for the main
course yes how do you think you did
29:15 what why one just been big risen
too greasy unbelievable yeah I
personally felt you don't [ __ ] good
job you can pull it back yes just come
up with dessert
yes next on the menu Sara Cox reveals
all in the recipe challenge instead I
ask the entire table is with the goal of
a gangbang
I give Olympic athletes a run for their
money with my fast food
and Duncan Ross files a police complaint
gonna sack the lot buildin I'm being
harassed
walking back the f-word now time for
another slippery challenge and it's time
for me also to beat Sarah Cox confident
to meet me or beat me but beat you beat
me alright nice to meet you yes I'm
quite confident yes Lee
that's your board there forget about
them good luck yes yes good luck to you
too sir so Sarah is making a chili con
carne I'm doing exactly the same mince
beef fresh oregano paprika sweet paprika
kidney beans slightly pure in the garlic
so it's not so intense and then finished
was really nice vine tomatoes so it
gives that a really nice sort of rich
dark peppery flavor but not too spicy
so for Sarah's chili special chopped
onion bit chopped garlic might Chuck in
a bit of red pepper some good beefy I
don't believe it's hair a foot but it is
British beef good got a bit smarter
puree might chucking a bit of wine
chopped tomatoes kidney beans I can it's
like the pong game map but basically I
just bummed it all and do that and then
drink a bit of wine and my secret
you've got an amazing food background
your father's a beef farmer important is
that right certainly it doesn't mainly
for the breed in really you know I think
he'll send one in when it's got a big
farm bill and so does have to have a
collection of bull semen every other
month well it's got good stock Bolognese
don't eat import some from Canada and
that coyote got longer legs or something
so you grew up eating lots of me yes
well yeah pigs cows did you ever get
attached to them
yeah I really they don't really bring
the piglet cause the like Charlotte's
Web was all the rage rough net and I
know it sounds like any therapy from
this story but I did actually use to go
to the to the abattoir of my dad when it
loaded all the pigs there
oh really and I used to cry myself to
sleep and then wake up when it was all
over you know I never went in to see
Albert while they don't know they never
the nice thing about it you understood
exactly from an early age where me yes
from yeah exactly the back garden
the main objective is get the kids up to
speed exactly where it comes from and be
I'm in that sort of debatable mood
whether or not to take them to the
abattoir and show them the final thing I
wasn't expensive bill years of therapy
that yeah
these are that would turn out to be
[ __ ] vegetarian darling walking in
some noisy Japan I'm happy it's alive
it's in there so your onions garlic yeah
from there what else is it there's my
fresh chili in there uh-huh
I'm gonna bring this beef off and then
I'm gonna whack in a glass the red wine
and let that bubble away I'm using leave
parent what's your seeking gradient I've
got a tin of baked beans you using what
innovate being I turn the baby ya know
hey so red wine with baked beans I can't
wait to take another the one thing I've
always admired about you you know that
is your bit like me you speak your mind
yeah what's the most embarrassing thing
you've ever said in the entire life
neither my moment taken I have all the
staff from her pop on the christmas meal
i meant for us to go old well and dance
but instead i ask the entire table if we
could all have a gangbang and everyone
just completely silent long just when
ashen and I didn't know what I meant and
I still to this day I kind of meant
there's a word out there isn't that but
at the ripe old age of 32 now you're
fully aware of what gangbang is now
don't you yeah you have no personal
experience LP Phillip brother
no quickly after actually what it was
known that all right I'm now gonna have
my ex martyrs these big beef tomatoes
are perfect the very juicy and they're
full of flavor
so with tomatoes is it fine to keep the
skin exhale we kind of put fresh
tomorrow in and I think all do I have to
don't come in boiling water and get the
skin off cuz something like you're
chilling something easy and
straightforward like that keeping the
skin on it's absolutely fine you know
that you've got a great figure you're a
slim do you watch carefully what you eat
or do you just sort of workout at the
same time I love food yeah I can be
quite athlete breakfast and other
planning what I want for lunch what I
want for dinner you eat well yeah I
didn't used to model and I didn't eat
well at all man there's like seven and a
half stories were faster than my thighs
look like 19 I lived on like you know
mal delights and coffee how do we modern
for a couple years I mean I wear that
success but I still mind just fitting
some ships behind me mum's bar at the
pub you traveled across the world model
minion stole in South Korea
two trips huh who's ever tried to make
you eat a dog out there in terms of that
did you know I'd eaten dog until I got
to the joints of the ball and then I
realized it wasn't chicken because it
was kind of a different structure what
does it taste of just deep fried meat
like kind of like chicken ala so both
swimmin out for 20 minutes okay then the
blind tasters will taste them and you'll
lose fast food doesn't have to mean
baked beans
[Music]
I've run eight marathons 26 long hard
miles each
and if there's one thing I've learnt is
that eating right is just as important
as the training so you'd think that two
super fast athletes training for the
Olympics would be eating a varied diet
in between training but they're not and
their excuses they say they've got no
time we train in the morning three or
four hours you know maybe have half an
hour for lunch and then back in training
the afternoon so in last six days a week
so it's busy schedule lunch times a
struggle because it's on the rush it's
on the go and it is just food for fuel
there's nothing interesting about it
it's all all a is this the ready-made
past apart it's literally just past
there makes it a bit of check-in a bit
of sauce just because we're training for
the Olympics we don't need anything
special in particular we just need to
eat good amounts of the right stuff I
want to learn how to cook something nice
quick tasty and I wanna be able to
impress my girlfriend I cannot cook so
I've come to be best mates Chris and
Andy to help them be as fast in the
kitchen as they are on the track
lightning that looks bloody fast
yeah and how many times a day you train
twice a day twice a day after day five
days a week six days a week six days a
week I mean that's extraordinary for one
goal an Olympic gold better history epic
stone yeah who's the fastest Wow hero
tonight it's me this is better but the
last time we raced a live TV I took you
about we do me a favor take me out oh I
wanna see just how fast you are
yeah use your 15 stone two years of age
yeah so go easy on the old man yes good
let's go
I felt like [ __ ] Shrek going over
there yeah I'll try this printing here
that says all the posture yeah yes okay
sorry sorry sorry I just get excited on
your mouths you know [ __ ]
no it's confirmed you're fast on the
track I'll show you how to be fast in
the kitchen
ready
right time-wise lunch you've got what
half an hour half an hour tell max yeah
run me through a normal lunch so what do
you have yesterday plaster pot and
that's it that's it I passed the pot
that's a faster [ __ ] I mean it looks
boring is boring yes it's my bored with
it by now no got it
I'll fed up the VIP pass it doesn't have
to be boring you know that so I'm gonna
come over three very exciting pasta
dishes we're gonna be fast furious and
delicious first recipe
why tomato sauce basil chili and finish
your prawns
[Music]
pasta is the ultimate fast food and
something I eat when I'm training for
the marathon yeah that's tough yeah
voter so at the time it takes to cook
that spaghetti this horse is ready yes
surely now and a little tip to do a roll
like that
this releases the seeds so you can
discard them easily
[Music]
and these puzzle in please I mean you
guys eat while learning yeah yeah you
don't have to follow a strict diet do
you know that's been in moderation it's
what you know ask me about you have the
perfect kind of food that we need why
rescue took even Farseer continued
pastor Manchester leeks and mushrooms
and if you can't get water pancetta
smoked bacon that'd be fine chop the
leeks finely and add to the bacon
I'm adults my goal is a gold medal in
Beijing in Beijing a defendant in your
hometown your own country hosting
villain fit after three minutes and some
creme fraiche which lightens the dish as
fast isn't it add some grated Parmesan
and finish with your chopped parsley
that's the kind of time scale recipe 3
this one good chicken goat sheep pilots
and runner beans
good runner beans in garlic why not sir
okay Rose wheel on there please cut take
the ingredients out the pan and prepare
the chicken chicken breast in a buzz
fire okay nice to keep the knife ice and
flat and just open up cutting the
chicken this way leads the breast
thinner and therefore it cooks quicker I
love that lies the stab you that's a
really nice dry goat cheese and I work
we're keeping in the freezer and perfect
for finishing pass that's a great tip
because they never go up this is not
boring is it
we can't rely on time as an excuse to
not look after yourselves no no all
three you happy with of course at this
one our particular we got the world
championship come here we have another
son
yeah I just hope the funky times are
faster the world championship golden how
are you
feral thing you how are you well if we
find them one time old age running older
wife it was not you want now honest
opinion she's flavor overpowered the
fish if you must use the palm is there
next time great the [ __ ] up
alright cubes of parmesan on their
simple project simply prepared are you
gonna pay for it yes that's the most
important I ain't none of the table is
but I oh my god what do you don't paying
for them all you're telling me how it
should be done yes that's how it should
be done [ __ ] it come with me yeah two
seconds if you want me do you want a yes
here we go let's go yeah here we go
right ladies this is a Moni diner to
make up yeah please negativity is gonna
give us a hand with the dessert
[Applause]
it is like something for that like the
New Romantics here you ladies you're
gonna have to help him right just turn
you on huh time for dessert one of my
favorites can you stop eating the
[ __ ] peaches pleasure pan perdu with
cameras peaches basically posh eggy
bread and the secret behind is of course
is using old bread if use all breads and
absorb all the nice egg mixture and it
get nice and crispy on the outside
peaches
hot pan sugar the secret now is to get
little bit of color on the peaches but
not getting the caramel too dark roast
once we got the color on the peaches
then we're gonna start adding the butter
battle now the basil just perfumes the
camel and just gives it's really nice
light sweet summery flavor out the
source for the pan perdu a really nice
fresh vibrant raspy coulis sugar lemon
straight on to the mixer
blitz and then get the bottom of your
ladle and just run that around soo
lovely eggy bread is very very simple
eggs vanilla smell absolutely delicious
I see sugar milk cream whisk so we got
this really nice sweet and fresh vanilla
custard mint that's ready for the
brioche
and I cut them plays nice big long
slices hot pan bread in and then back
out not too long into the pan up and
over I've literally done in seconds
[Applause]
in kakuni down one side mint icing sugar
pan perdu with cameras peaches and raspy
cooling done that is the perfect summer
on a plate
let's give one our time and we'll do it
together yes is that being on the
generation game a day in nicely yeah
peaches in I set your camera lies the
mint
good good okay good that's nice mine's
ready chef
yeah right good onto the board please
right Jonathan you're gonna do the bread
yes yet the girls can do the baccala
absolutely just don't one no no maybe or
49 more to do just just a little bit I
wouldn't have bought them a bath do it
right ladies let's go
joki that's good trust me you've lost
weight already funny video this is easy
I'm gonna be difficult right least
that's to burn there now down yes
not that that's too dark there yeah
point it again tell them keep it going
yes thank you though yes yeah I don't
mind saying yes chef the same pile
Wham's oh I pour the liner
chef I made a smiley face with the
butter in the pan here we go well I
think I found it feel me a cream on top
Mars yep are you happy with them fresh
that's on this five yes service please
it's only they've eaten enough out there
the greedy pigs all night oh I'm so
happy you're sweating last time we did
that your interview Fanny Cradock are
they looking good Lisa you've perfected
it now have you seen I'm being collapse
on Bangkok for ya oh come on cook for
you oh that's a far less interesting
proposition now we've got four more
tables to send yes I'm getting tired
[Music]
next on the menu Sara and I await the
final verdict how'd it go we win they
work my lamb Gavin says goodbye to his
mum and John Ross joined the police
lineup this is a big moment
welcome back the effort now time to find
out who's won the recipe challenge and
whose [ __ ] stood up right Jemma's
portion yes no skimping now we'll play
it up shall we
okay rice is that yeah make a well in
the middle is exactly now feeling
confident yeah
Giselle sorry no right yeah do that can
I take this all my fries it yeah right
John Baptist please
sadly yes yeah okay Sarah's gone good
hi how are you right away thank you your
first dish in this number two Ben
Appetit thank you thank you what's your
spicy though it's quite sweet actually
tastes like it's got that much chili in
it and I think that baked beans
yeah that's really that's what you can
taste a little too every time is that in
it that's a smaller tomatoes to take
bringing the plate before I detect quite
a lot of salt French cocky how'd it go
we went very well very very well yeah
obviously
yeah always goes well yeah well done
Gordon well done thank you do me a favor
yeah
I'm still no closer to finding out what
happened to Charlotte but I've now got
to concentrate on getting Gavin back
home farmer may has come to help me
relocate him well I'm afraid you lose
some in farming and threats a quick look
on the tree these don't look damaged at
all you know yeah I got hold of these so
you happy with that condition oh yes
definitely
yeah well Gavin's not enough to feed 50
dinars the Claridge's so to keep him
company and crucially give me enough
meat for my restaurant mais brought me
to new lands at 13 weeks Gavin is
getting too old to keep suckling from
his mother so he has to be weaned or
separated from the parent splitting up a
lamb and its mother is a harsh reality
of farming so it's gonna be a bit of a
peculiar yeah you know he's calling they
call him for each other now put those
swords insane and Marie is taking the
news back to Wales tried carefully yes
[Music]
and I'm taking the Lambs to my garden in
London where Hoover Leawood installed is
waiting
you've now got the situation where these
two new incomers
they're used to the Welsh Hills I'm not
gonna send them anywhere else they're
staying in my back garden what you have
to hope is that he's gonna teach them
yeah how does they come how to stay calm
in suburbia welcome home
listen unfortunately we've got some bad
news to explain Charlotte got eaten we
don't know it may be a dog or a wild cat
listen I'm not blaming your cat for
eating them okay no they should be
settling down well I think they're
settling down right and I think they're
really encouraging thing is that they
look like a trio already that's a little
flock you've got there a nice little
flock of three you can tell which one is
the original very easy to identify look
Gavin's got the full tail and the other
two girls are no he's not hard at all
you know what we did last time I was
here when when when Gavin was only small
yes we gave Charlotte and Gavin it a
hill that's right I think we've got to
give them a bigger hill
Hugh's pulling out all the stops to make
sure the Lambs are as happy as possible
in their final weeks over here but nice
it's a snug fit not this bloody roof
again is that the front could be yeah
Jack or is it the back let's get the
grass on the roof [ __ ] end up with
utopia Gordon just let me make a noise
[Applause]
check it out phase 1 that's your man
isn't it
yeah that's Kevin yeah no do you still
think I'm mad later that evening all
three lamps finally reached the top of
the mountain how cool is that cool that
will grow this thing grass will always
grow and lamb is delicious that's the
only thing you ought to think about
tonight when you get better best laugh
tables yes wait Jonathan yes five six of
the best now yes here we go oh come on
baby don't do that to me please pops
nice ladies that was fast
I've never seen him work so hard really
complimented it it's not something that
I would think of putting with a dessert
but it was great I love to definitely
papers I'm definitely happy to get as
well okay GB yes come on so ladies for
safa 34 out of 50 yeah yeah pretty good
yeah not perfect but not bad yes main
course 2950 not good enough this yes
is it big moment bring it up bring it up
ladies for dessert yes
out of 50 dinars 48 have agreed to pack
[Applause]
bloody good work you know that [ __ ]
good work
the total is yeah out of 150 is 111
I'm so sorry not becoming about declared
the second best so far [ __ ] clothes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
on everything what's wrong with you
simple pas juste simply prepare